[Music]
after a massive storm tears through the
hex archipelago you find five grizzled
survivors in the water
shivering their Timbers they explained
that they're the former crew of the
great pirate green beard who marooned
them after they tried to mutiny each was
bound up in a different spot on a small
island until the storm washed them out
to sea in gratitude for saving them they
reveal a secret the island they were on
is also where green beard has buried his
treasure hoard but when the sailors try
to describe the island something seems
off all agree it was flat and barren
with no prominent features except for
some trees yet each pirate claims they
saw a different number of trees ranging
from two to six the pirate who saw two
trees says the treasure was buried right
at his feet when you fly your hot-air
balloon over the area to investigate you
see hundreds of small islands each with
exactly six trees the next storm will be
here soon so you'll have to hurry and
narrow your search what does the island
with green beards treasure look like
from the sky and where will the treasure
be on that island
you
it might seem like the Pirates are
delirious from dehydration but that's
not what's going on remember each was
confined to a separate point on the
island and no two of them could see the
same number of trees that means that for
all but one pirate something was
blocking their view and since there are
no other features on the island that
something could only have been other
trees a pirate would see fewer trees
when two or more fell along a straight
line from their vantage point so we need
to find the island where five different
pirates standing in different spots
would each see a different number of
trees
virtually every island has a position
from which you can see six trees and on
most islands there's a position where
five trees can be seen by standing in
line with two of them it turns out that
the hardest locations to find are those
with fewer visible trees precisely
because they require more trees to line
up with the viewers position so how can
we see just two trees one way would be
if all the trees were lined up in single
file such as on this island then you
could stand at the end of the line and
see one stand in the middle and see two
or stand anywhere else and see all six
but there's no place from which you can
see only three four or five so one
straight line of trees is out so what
about two lines of trees so long as the
lines aren't parallel and they intersect
over land there will always be a
position where the two lines converge
from which you could see exactly two
trees and if there groups two and four
or three and three
there are many Arrangements in which you
could also see three four five
and six trees fortunately for us there's
only one island in the archipelago with
two non-parallel lines of trees and
it'll be buried at the intersection of
the two lines you land on this island
and dig up a chest containing a massive
pile of tree seeds ready for planting
was this treasure really worth all that
trouble that's a matter of perspective
do you subscribe to the ted-ed riddle
series if so then two months ago you
narrowly escaped the eccentric wizard
last month you locked up the elusive
space rebels you just snagged some seeds
from green beard and there are many
riddles to come we want you to be able
to solve any riddle you encounter and we
have the perfect place for you to hone
your problem-solving skills
brilliant offers an amazing library of
puzzles to help you master all kinds of
problem-solving techniques they take
tough problems break them up into
bite-sized concepts and help you build
them back up into stunning solutions
using brilliant we'll help you apply new
tools to novel situations and help you
solve future ted-ed riddles visit
brilliant org slash ted-ed or click the
link below to get started on your
problem-solving journey creating a
brilliant user account is free but if
you decide to create a premium account
the first 833 of you to do so through
this link will receive 20% off the
annual subscription fee thanks